>>Catherine: These are the keys to
participating in a conversation fully.
>>Pamela: Sometimes we all need
a little bit of a kick-starter
to feel like we can contribute.
>>Children are going to struggle a bit,
depending on how confident they feel,
in speaking up in class and yet
this teacher wants everybody
in the class to feel valued.
So the kids are all learning phrases
that can inspire other kids
to contribute more easily.
>>Catherine: We're trying
to build a conversation here
that is a community of
caring and respect.
So look at your talk
moves on the table today,
and I have a post-it note here for you.
>>Talk moves are essentially sentence
starters that students can use
to get themselves into the conversation,
and to draw other people
into the conversation.
>>I taped the talk moves
right on the table,
so that they would be ever
present in everyone's mind.
>>Today, I want you to keep
track of your talk moves.
>>Every time they used a talk move,
they'd put a check on their sticky note.
>>So if somebody at your table looks
like they don't have a
talk move check mark yet,
invite them into the
conversation. How could you do that?
>>Philip: Say, like,
"What do you think?"
>>Catherine: Definitely.
Would you use their name?
>>Philip: Yeah.
>>Catherine: Awesome.
>>Pamela: Everything about activating
a child's cognitive skills begins
with activating their
social connectedness.
Verbalizing and using language, and
working with peers creates that kind
of social stimulus that drives
the development of the brain.
>>Philip: I pretty much look
at the thing every single time,
to see if there's something I can
say, like a clarifying question.
>>Can you explain more about,
like why you would get in trouble?
>>Salma: He spray painted something
on his rival soccer team's school.
>>When you ask a person a clarifying
question, it's either, "Oh,
I heard you said," or, "Can
you repeat what you said?"
or "To add onto."
>>Catherine: They help enormously
with language learners. They
give everybody a platform to jump
into a conversation, because half the
sentence is there for them already.
But they also challenge other types
of learners who may be accustomed
to doing independent work,
and they need a bridge
to collaborate more with a group.
It pushes kids out of their comfort
zone of social conversations,
and it moves them more
towards a professional
and an academic kind of register.
>>Student: All his accomplishments
and tasks,
like all the other marches he
had, like Martin Luther King--
>>Student: I heard you say
previous marches. Like,
does it say it say anything
about what he was involved with?
>>Student: Yeah, like he was
in Martin Luther King marches.
>>Catherine: I do talk moves because,
in order to have a great discussion,
everyone has to feel like
they're a part of it, and valued.
And when they walk away, they really
have bridged a gap with someone
that maybe they wouldn't necessarily
talked to, or talked to on that level.
>>Pamela: This teacher is aware of
children having different levels
of comfort and discomfort, of
making their skills visible,
and she's getting kids to
support each other's participation
with these talk moves.
This teacher created a pathway for every
single child in this class to belong.